how did you figure out to start with why
why not what or
how right i mean who's on first right i
mean it's
why start with y is based on biology
okay i mean i recognize that there was a
pattern
in how how great marketers would market
themselves like
you know that they would all speak in
the same way which i thought was
interesting
and i wrote down that pattern and the
original golden circle was
why what how and i went and
when i how did you figure that when did
that happen for you
a long time ago i was simply trying to
figure out why some marketing worked in
some marketing didn't
when you were with your marketing no
when i when i started my own okay
uh because i knew that some did and some
didn't yeah and it wasn't the creative
team
because the same creative team could
make good stuff and bad stuff
and it wasn't the client so there had to
be something
else at work so i recognized there was a
pattern
and i wrote down that pattern and
i met somebody at a at a it was a
dinner party whose parents were
neuroscientists and she started telling
me about the limbic brain and the
neocortex
and it was interesting and i went and
read about it when i got home
which it's like neuroscience 101 it's
not that it's not controversial
in a neuroscience yeah and i realized
that little idea that i had on a shelf
overlapped perfectly with how people
make decisions so
that's why that worked in marketing but
that means it was bigger than marketing
is
it was about how we operate all the time
and so i started talking about this
thing called the golden circle and
eventually sought out council from a
famous neuroscientist
named dr peter weibrow
i needed him to look at the idea because
i'm not a neuroscientist and i was
saying this overlaps with the human
brain was that even true
yeah um and so i spent a weekend with
him and like
filled him with all my ideas and i
remember
sunday morning he walked in
uncomfortable i said what's bothering
you peter
he said you have it in the wrong order
if you want it to match the biology
it has to go why how what your
definitions are fine
but if you want it to match the brain it
has to go why how wet and it went done
yeah well you got the y in the middle
then of course why was the middle that
that was the most important that was the
piece that was missing yeah but it does
it overlaps with the biology of human
decision making
so it's not my opinion yeah it's biology
yeah um and it's
and it's why to your point it's why
sales works it's why relationships work
it's why all these things because it's
how people
[Music]
work